in the past year as people were forced
into the comfort of their homes by the
pandemic they were welcomed in open arms
by one of the most addictive pastimes of
any homebody
television
comcast reported that the average
household was watching over eight hours
more every week in the midst of covet
19's first worldwide spike and the
information gathering company nielsen
found an average increase of 61
in streaming video from your tv
and as a result expectedly this also
drove the popularity of anime to new
heights and let it soar as one of the
most popular forms of entertainment over
the past year
earlier in 2021 attack on titan was the
most in-demand show
not just anime but actual show airing in
the entire united states an
unprecedented feat for anime thus far
but while anime as an industry soars the
workers and animators who keep said
industry running behind the scenes
are arguably worse off than ever before
as the gap between company profits and
worker wages continues to widen
today i'll be discussing the harsh
reality of being a japanese animator and
what it means to pursue your artistic
passion in the midst of anime's most
popular time across the world
in my last video i detailed the sad
truth of being a mangaka a manga author
and though the topics are similar i
believe it would be a disservice to
compare being a mangaka and an animator
directly
let alone put them in the same video
manga and anime though connected are two
very different industries as is the work
that goes into each
nor is either completely that bad if it
may seem that way
being an animator means that you can
work directly on something you love
frame by frame you can put your all into
a product for the whole world to see and
contribute to animation that inspired
you growing up
but as with any job but even more so
with being an animator
it's necessary to weigh the cons of it
all as one of the most cut-throat
industries in the world
despite the anime industry bringing in
over 21 billion dollars in 2019
according to the association of japanese
animations poll of animators for their
on average workday of about 12 hours a
number that already shouldn't be scoffed
at fifty percent felt like their wages
were insufficient compared to the work
that they put in
in a new york times article interviewing
tetsuya akutu who's worked as a head
animator on episodes of shows like
darling in the franxx and made in abyss
he claimed to earn about fourteen
hundred dollars to thirty eight hundred
dollars a month or about seventeen
thousand to 46 000 a year as a top
animator
because of how much time he has to
devote daily to the job and the
financial instability he acknowledges
that it's impossible to get married and
to raise a child as an animator in japan
it's almost as if you can't even have
your own life
and even though a range of seventeen
thousand to forty six thousand is
nothing to be scoffed at compared to his
american counterparts in animation this
pales in comparison to their average of
65 000 a year or more
and even akutu as overworked and
underpaid as he is is frankly
one of the lucky ones
he is what this new york times article
noted as a ganga man the more renowned
generally freelance animators who get
hired to work on key episodes or scenes
and this is contrasted by the dogaman
more common entry-level animators who
work frame by frame to connect those key
illustrations together
to make well
animation
for them that forty five thousand
dollars what already seems like a low
number for the amount of work he puts in
that number is only a dream to them
27 of the animators participating in the
poll about wages said that they earned
less than 1 million yen or about 10 000
annually
the average was said to be about 12 000
a year in 2019 barely a reasonable
salary for any job
and this is all on top of the fact that
the large majority of animators live in
tokyo renowned as one of the most
expensive cities in the world
it isn't a far stretch to say that for a
million yen a year living in japan isn't
an easy task
and to escape the poor salary deals many
work without contracts as freelance but
that means that they don't have company
benefits like health insurance while
arguably working just as hard
and some animators don't even do as well
as others in other specializations as
well the most highly paid storyboard
animators for example who draw frames to
plan out the episodes reportedly only
receive 80 percent of other kinds of
animators
but doing what you love isn't always
about the money in fact for most
artistic pursuits money almost always
takes a second or third priority
but with the amount of work that
japanese animators have to do
burnout and exhaustion are significant
issues for those working towards their
passions that must be taken into
consideration
another survey supports the earlier
claim of an average of 12 hour work days
for animators this one averaging out to
11.
but it's not like they spend half of the
entire day to work overtime so that they
can say have less work the next day
actually over 50 percent of those
surveyed had four or less days off in
the entire month
including weekends taking the idea of
karoshi death by overwork to its extreme
i talked very in depth about the idea of
karoshi in my video about mangakas and
how they work to the bone for each and
every chapter so go and watch that video
if you want to further understand the
term itself but it essentially refers to
the very common culture of overwork
within japan's workforce where
stretching your body's limits for work
is almost like a badge of honor rather
than a significant concern
twelve plus hours of work a day for
thirty dollars not even a full weekend
off at the end of the week it can't even
be considered minimum wage really
but don't get me wrong this isn't always
forced on them in fact it is an inherent
cultural standard in japan to want to
work for a collective purpose and devote
yourself entirely for that sake
it is voluntary and it does stem from
each animators or each of japan's
workers really their passion for their
work
some decide it's not worth it
hirakimoto quit the industry after his
first child was born after many years of
never making more than 38 dollars a day
but most do stick with it according to
hirakimoto no matter how little some of
them got paid
they were willing to do the work
and so there is a really important
question that must be addressed which is
why doesn't it change
why don't conditions and wages improve
why is animation so grueling
well a big aspect of the problem is that
the supply of aspiring animators is
relatively inelastic meaning that
companies can keep wages just about as
low as they want and still receive a
stable supply if not an influx actually
of workers
because there are so many young
animators passionate about creating
anime who dream of making it big and
working on this art form most costs are
acceptable to them
after all it isn't a dead-end job being
an animator hayao miyazaki the famed
co-founder of studio ghibli and hideaki
anno the director of neon genesis
evangelion both began as mere animators
you can become a director or supervisor
all of which do pay reasonably
though of course that doesn't
necessarily mean any less work just more
reasonable pay for it
simone stanzani a translator in the
animation business for over three
decades now described this inelastic
trend in more blunt terms
she said that studios have a lot of
cannon fodder they have no reason to
raise wages
the excessive hours and low wages are
allegedly in violation of japanese labor
laws
japan's labor ministry said the
government is aware of the problem but
had little recourse unless animators
themselves filed a complaint
and such because most are willing to put
up with it nothing really changes
because japan in general cultivates a
work environment of avoiding direct
confrontation and working your hardest
no matter what the problem persists
but that culture of keeping your head
down doesn't go for everyone
in the midst of arguably mapa's studio's
biggest and busiest year ever in 2020
heading productions of attack on titan
season 4 energy to kyson the two most
popular anime of the year
several accusations of insanely low wage
rates from their workers arose
they claimed to have factory-like
unhealthy working conditions
working them until the sun came up
and though this problem actually seemed
to be rooted in the fact that netflix
wasn't willing to pay mapa enough budget
proportionally to the amount of work
going into the projects it doesn't
change the fact that its ultimate
downstream effect
fell onto the workers who felt obligated
to speak up
and also not every company is some
horrible machine pumping the life out of
their animators if that's what it made
it seem like kyoto animation is known
for giving employees favored salaries
instead of always outsourcing to
freelancers the cheaper and more common
option
and so at the end of the day the issue
is systemic
it is built upon restrictive budgets
from production committees and the
japanese culture of overwork and the
almost indistinguishable passion of
young animators to work on the anime
they love it's difficult to even think
about the fact that a form of media that
brings millions joy and entertainment
rides on the back of so much exhausting
work
leave a comment on what you think i
always encourage discussion and opinions
on such a controversial and difficult
topic
and as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses